When you write a fraction,
there are actually
words for the top number
and the bottom number.
And the words are
a lot more fancy
than the word "top number"
and "bottom number."
What mathematicians
typically use
is the word "numerator" for the
top number and "denominator"
for the bottom number.
And what I want to do now that
we know that the top number is
the numerator of the fraction
and the bottom number is
the denominator,
I want to compare
pairs of fractions that have
either the same denominator
or the same numerator.
So let's look at
this first pair.
I want to compare 4/7 to 3/7.
And I have two wholes
right over here.
They're the same hole, and I've
divided them into sevenths.
I've divided them
into 7 equal chunks.
And I want to see what's
larger, 4/7 or 3/7.
So what I can do is,
I can fill in 4/7.
Let me select 4 out of the 7.
So, that's 1, 2, 3, 4.
And the fact that trying to even
get to 4/7 I had to have 3/7
first gives you good clue
that 4/7 is probably larger,
or it is larger.
But now let's color in 3/7,
just so we can compare.
So 1, 2, 3/7.
And so it's pretty clear
that on the left-hand side,
we are shading in
more of the whole
than on the right-hand side.
So, 4/7 represents
a larger fraction,
more of the whole than 3/7.
And the way that we can state
that comparison mathematically
is with the greater than symbol.
We can write 4/7 is
greater than 3/7.
Now, the greater than
and less than symbols
can sometimes be confusing.
This is greater than.
This is less than.
And the way that
I remember it is
that the greater than symbol,
either symbol, the small pointy
side is always on the
side of the smaller
number, and the big
open side is always
on the side of
the larger number.
So here, big open
side is opening
towards the 4/7, small pointy
side opening to the 3/7.
4/7 is greater than 3/7.
Now, what about 3/7 and 3/4?
So, here I have
different denominators,
but I have the same numerator.
And so I encourage you
to pause this video
and draw maybe little
boxes like this
and try to judge for yourself
which of these is a larger
fraction, represents
a larger number.
Well, let's color them in.
So, let's think about 3/7 first.
And we actually
already drew it here,
but I can do it really
fast right over here.
So that is 3/7.
I've colored in 3 of
the 7 equal groups.
And what would 3/4 be?
Well, that's 1/3, 2/4, and 3/4.
And so it's pretty clear
that 3/4 represents a larger
fraction of the whole,
that 3/4 is larger,
or that 3/7 is smaller.
So we could write that
3/7 is less than 3/4.
So, notice, same
exact numerator.
When I divided it-- because
this fraction symbol
could also be
viewed as division.
When I have it as
more equal groups,
so it's a fraction of
more equal groups, so 3
out of 7 versus 3 out of 4,
this is a smaller number,
which which makes sense.
Now, let's compare these two.
We have the same denominator,
different numerators-- 3/4
versus 2/4.
Well, 3/4 we've
already looked at.
We can just shade in 3 of these.
So 3 of these fourths.
So that's 3/4 right over there.
And then 2/4, well,
we're going to only
have 2 of the fourths, 1, 2.
So 2/4 is clearly
the smaller number.
3/4 is the greater number.
So, once again, we could
write 3/4 is greater than 2/4.
And then finally, I encourage
you to pause the video.
Try to come up with whether
2/4 or 3/6 is a larger number.
Well, let's color it in again.
We've already seen 2/4.
We just have to color
in 2 of our fourths.
So let's just color in 2 of
our fourths right over there.
And then 3/6, we've
split our whole
into 6 equal sections--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
We need to color in 3 of them.
And as you see, we're coloring
in the exact same amount
of the whole.
These two fractions
are equivalent.
These are equivalent fractions.
2/4 is equal to 3/6.
And as you see
here, they're both
filling in half of the whole.
If we were to just draw
the whole and split
it only-- let me do this
in a different color.
If we have our whole, and
we were to split it only
into two sections,
we are shading
in exactly 1 out
of the 2 sections.
So you could say that
2/4 is equal to 3/6,
and they both equal 1/2.
So 1/2 is equal to
2/4 is equal to 3/6.